Let's talk about one of the most fundamental ideas in science - the idea of ​​energy.
Usually we imagine things that move or are hot and bright,
as energetic, but what I'm going to talk about in this video,
is a more formal, more scientific definition.
The most typical explanation given is the ability to work.
But I will put "work" in quotes, why the idea of ​​working here is not the same
such as in the everyday life when you go to work from 9:00 to 5:00 and get a salary.
In the context of physics, work is not entirely different from this idea
to work in our everyday life, but I will give you an example to make you clearer.
Let's say there's some object here and you're going to apply force
in this way.
Let's say this force is from 10 Newtons.
If the Newton unit and the notion of force are not very familiar to you,
do not worry, you can recall them from these videos from the Cannes Academy.
So, you apply force to the right of the object
and thus you can move the object,
to change its location in the same direction of power.
Let's say you move him 10 meters.
When you're done, the object is already here. And so by applying force
you make the object move to space in the direction of that force
And it can be said that work has been done. And the amount of work done
is 10 newtons of 10 meters. 10 by 10 is equal to 100.
And then the unit of work is Newton-meter - 100 Newton meters.
Because we multiply the Newtons by the meters.
Newton-meter is defined as a joule - it is a unit of work and the same unit of energy.
That's the same 100. I can write 100 joules.
Abbreviatedly we can write it with J.
So here are 100 joules of work
by moving this.
We have done something here that is considered a job - 100 joules of work.
If we move this two times farther, then we will have 200 joules of work.
So energy is the ability to do such work.
Now let's take a look at these photos here,
representing different forms of energy.
And let's see if we can determine which are these forms
how they can relate to actual work.
If we look at the fire here, there are some obvious ones
forms of energy - we have some thermal energy.
The fire is definitely hot, so we have thermal energy.
But we need to think about what is thermal energy at its core:
the temperature of a system is the average kinetic energy of its molecules.
Therefore, thermal energy is the real energy of motion.
It's really relevant to all these little molecules here.
Because of the combustion reaction, they are excited and have higher kinetic energy.
And so the temperature rises, their average kinetic energy rises.
Therefore, thermal energy is actually a form of energy caused by motion.
The basic term for motion energy is kinetic energy,
so that thermal energy is a real form of kinetic energy.
You also have the light of light that has energy.
We call it light energy because light is emitted.
This is the reason we can see this fire.
Light energy.
Now you might think that it's probably all the energy in the system.
But I will say: No. There is another form of energy.
And even on this picture most of the energy is safe here.
And this is the potential energy. And where exactly is she?
It is locked in fuel connections here,
whether pieces of wood or coal or other - they are all made of carbon,
of carbon bonds. And you have these carbon bonds. They may be connected
with other carbons or other things. They will also be related to hydrogen atoms in places.
So you will have different connections in this way,
who store energy in themselves with the potential to be released:
if you can break these chains, these electrons
will enter a state of low energy or will connect
with other things. And in the process will release energy, which
will be light and thermal / kinetic energy.
How does that work?
How do these links actually break up?
This is through our good old friend - the burning reaction,
where you take a little oxygen and heat
(or we can say a little energy). It takes a little energy to get started.
So maybe you have to burn this with a match match at first.
So we need oxygen plus energy. And you can say plus these carbon bonds.
Ie. plus what this fuel here is from carbon compounds:
whether coal or wood. I will write it this way:
any carbon-carbon bonds here are going to ignite.
I will color this. (I have a problem with changing colors.)
It will ignite and release,
will release water because the fuel has hydrogen in itself.
And it will release carbon dioxide. And much more energy. I will write it in capital letters.
It will release a lot of energy. And we see this energy
in the form of the kinetic energy of the molecules and the separated light energy.
Now you might say, Well, I can assume I have this potential energy.
And this potential energy, which is in the bonds between these atoms -
we call it chemical potential. We have chemical potential energy.
The potential energy is here.
But maybe you're saying, "I understand that.
The chemical energy is transformed into thermal energy and
light energy. "This is actually an interesting idea for energy -
it is a law for the preservation of energy. It can not be created or destroyed.
It can only be transformed from one form to another. But you must say,
"Okay, I can turn it from one form to another, but how do that
can it do a real job, the way it was depicted at the beginning? "
Well, the whole industrial revolution aims to transform one form of energy into another
and to do the job accordingly.
The steam engine is built to heat steam by burning.
And then this steam is expanding and pushes the pistons that do all things,
including trains. Burning occurs in automotive engines,
in which the pistons expand because of the thermal energy.
And that makes the parts of the car work.
Here are some other examples. It's lightning -
when we have a flash, something very clearly kinetic happens.
You have electrons moving from a cloud cloud to the ground.
And maybe you're saying, here's kinetic energy.
You may be wondering: how can I do this?
That's what the whole electronics industry is all about. This is the basis
of electric cables - the movement of electrons. This is an electric current.
And he can be used to do any incredible things.
There may be an electric motor: this is one way to do the job.
This is kinetic energy. Obviously, we have light energy,
we can see the flash. And the light energy is produced,
because the air is ionizing and heating. That's why we also have thermal energy.
The electrons descend down and heat is generated.
And where did this energy come from? She has not come from nowhere.
You have all this potential energy that begins to accumulate
in these clouds, with the increase in water vapor. The mechanisms of action are not
fully understood. It's not quite clear how it happens. But we know it because of it
the energy from the sun has rising water vapor, and with the increase in the clouds,
the lower side becomes more negatively charged. It becomes richer in electrons.
And the top of the cloud becomes more positively charged.
And you have these electrons that really want to descend to the ground.
And because the air above ground becomes more negative, the earth is getting up
more positive. And you can imagine these electrons want more and more
and more to come down here. This air, however, is not a natural conductor.
But when the electrical potential rises up enough, the electrons find their way.
The air is ionized and the electrons can find a path down.
As long as all this accumulates, you have accumulated this electrostatic potential.
Electrostatic.
(Oh, I can not see the writing.)
You have electrostatic potential.
And how is he formed ... once again this is an area in which people are still discussing
some good theories about his formation,
but not yet 100% established.
And here in the third picture we have a man who jumps from a stand of hands.
This is probably the most typical example you can find in a physics textbook
to turn potential energy into kinetic energy.
Here at the top of the tram the man
there is potential energy because of its position
and there is an obvious potential to fall and the potential to turn the potential
energy in kinetic. At the moment of falling most of the
potential energy has become kinetic.
This is potential, and it is kinetic energy.
So the big conclusion is that energy is the ability to do the job.
It can not be created or destroyed,
but it can move from one form to another.
And all forms at its core - you can think of them
as for two large buckets as for potential energy
and kinetic energy. For the last example, you may be asking yourself:
"But how does this person work?"
Imagine if there is a system here.
We create some mechanisms.
Maybe there is a reel here and it raises weight here.
If he jumps, he will not fall so fast,
but while heavier than this, the weight will pull down.
And this weight goes up. So he has the potential to do the job
because of its position here. But it does not really have this reel system,
to do the job.